[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à strasbourg au
parlement européen ravi de vous
retrouver pour cette première édition d'
europe hebdo version 2010 est dans cette
émission retour sur les 15 ans de l'euro
depuis la crise de 2008 les monnaies
locales se multiplient signe d'un
désamour pour une monnaie souvent décrié
pour être calqué sur le modèle allemand
est souvent accusée d'avoir fait flamber
les prix ce sera l'occasion de découvrir
notre checkpoint une nouvelle rubrique
de fact checking en partenariat avec la
rtbf mais d'abord l'actualité après 4e
round de vote et beaucoup de votre ville
le parlement s'est choisi son président
il s'agit d'antonio tajani 63 ans ancien
membres fondateurs de forza italia et
ancien porte parole de silvio berlusconi
retour sur la guerre de succession au
parlement avec aurélie dares
[Musique]
c'est fini pour martin schulz le
président du parlement européen l'avait
annoncé en novembre dernier il ne sera
pas candidat à sa propre succession
il quitte l'institution bruxelloise pour
revenir à la politique nationale
allemande
un départ qui a déclenché une véritable
guerre de succession
les groupes politiques s'étaient
pourtant accordé en 2014 pour mettre en
place une alternance à la tête du
parlement
avec le départ du socialiste martin
schulz à droite revendique donc le
perchoir
mais la gauche ne l'entend plus de cette
oreille elle ne souhaite pas que
l'ensemble des institutions de l'union
reviennent de conservateurs déjà à la
tête de la commission et du conseil
européens
dernier coup en date chez les libéraux
cette fois l'hiver hoofstadt candidat à
la présidence était prête à intégrer les
italiens du mouvement 5 étoiles pour
élargir son assise électorale un coup
manqué il a été désavoué par les
eurodéputés de son groupe défavorables à
une alliance avec des élus qui prône
notamment la sortie de l'euro toutes ces
tractations pourraient bien laisser des
traces
le parlement sera-t-il désormais
ingouvernable
[Musique]
un parlement potentiellement
ingouvernable après l'élection
controversée où tout dix mois on va être
plein de votre ville laquelle on a
assisté cette semaine de antonio tajani
donc italien de 63 ans conservateur et
ancien commissaire européen pour en
débattre andreas schwab
vous êtes député européen justement
membre du groupe ppe vous êtes allemand
bienvenue à vous en face de vous pascal
durand vous êtes membre d'europe
écologie les verts du groupe
merci à vous alors première question est
ce que antonio tajani c'est un bon
président andrés femmes on va voir ça
mais je pense qu'il sera un candidat
sérieux
c'est le premier italien en tête du
parlement européen s'était un temps de
le réaliser et nous avons voté en 2014
sur base d'un accord avec les
socialistes et libéraux pour arrêtée par
martin schulz avait pas exactement pour
martin schulz un candidat que nous
n'avons pas aimé mais estimée à la fin
re et maintenant les socialistes
malheureusement ont pas voulu voter pour
antonio tajani
notre candidat heureusement le parlement
a pris la bonne décision car c'est quand
même maintenant pour nous comme plus
grande force dans ce parlement d'avoir
le président met alors à quel prix parce
que c'est quand même une alliance et au
prix d'une alliance avec les libéraux de
guy verhofstadt qui se sont ralliées à 9
heures du matin avant le début des votes
puis beaucoup plus tard dans la journée
un ralliement du groupe c est donc les
conservateurs réformiste un groupe qui
est quand même très à droite pascal
durand est ce que ce micmac en fait ces
petites cuisines ne venait pas une
manière ça ne risque pas d'entacher
encore l'image du parlement alors vous
avez tout dit avec le thermique maeght
petite cuisine ralliement négociations
de couloir en fait qui est
regrettable dans cette élection c'est
qu'on n'a pas vu projets européens
portés on n'a pas vu de débats de fond
du tout le fait que monsieur verhofstadt
qui était censé porter une robe très
très dynamique très volontaire se retire
sur des négociations de couloir dont on
ignore tout et qu'on apprend à une
minute du commencement des votes ne
grandit pas notre institution voilà moi
je n'ai pas de problème sur le principe
que le groupe le plus important c'est à
dire le ppe soit au perchoir dirige
c'est la démocratie ça j'ai pas de
problème avec ça mais simplement ça
s'est fait dans des conditions je pense
qu'andré avait regrette tout en tant que
moi ça s'est fait dans des conditions
qui ne sont pas dignes d'une démocratie
moderne
voilà ce que vous êtes d'accord de
surcroît le groupe cr est quand même
composé pour beaucoup de conservateurs
britanniques on va donner des postes
dans le cadre de cette coalition à des
britanniques qui vont potentiellement
sortir donc de l'union européenne dans
des ans et ça c'est fait le même jour
que le discours de theresa may sur le
break site
la symbolique est pas terrible quand
même alors il faut dire positivement
parce qu'à la raison les verts ont une
position très claire et nette dès le
début nous avons eu un accord pas avec
les verts mais avec les socialistes et
les libéraux
nous avons pensé qu'ils vont tenir leurs
promesses cet accord de 2014 à et c'est
dommage que ça s'est fait comme pascal à
des crises et c'est regrettable mais
nous avons pas eu le choix on pouvait
pas dire maintenant on change tout notre
principe a été les socialistes premier
tour nous au deuxième et maintenant ça
c'est fait malheureusement cette
association casser l'accord
effectivement malheureusement dans des
conditions respectables
est ce que cette coalition elle pas un
peu contre nature aussi avec les
conservateurs réformiste tout poil et
sûr dans ce parlement est un peu contre
nature
d'une part nous avons dit avec les
libéraux que nous voulons que l'europe
avance que nous donner des réponses à
des problèmes concrète de l'europe
de l'autre côté nous avons dit avec les
cerfs que nous voulons que toutes les
groupes au parlement européen soit mis
en valeur un truc qui malheureusement
s'est pas fait les derniers mois et donc
c'est des coalitions
des compromis pas toujours facile mais
c'est l'europe et donc il faut
maintenant pas être toujours négatif sur
le compromis il faut voir que les
groupes ont finalement trouvé un accord
qui maintenant j'aspire matin au
parlement d'avancer rapidement on va
avoir un problème dire que l'on va avoir
un problème parce qu'on n'a pas eu le
sentiment qu'il y ait un projet de fonds
s'était d'ailleurs un des problèmes de
la grande coalition départ et et on doit
bien fait de rappeler que nous n'étions
pas dedans
ll a été trop opaques c'est à dire
qu'elle a eu lieu comme une répartition
des postes est d aider je te donne
saturne là bon et là on va voir quand
même un problème majeur parce que vous
l'avez dit l'accord entre le cerf le
cers et les tories anglais donc et les
théories anglais ils sont passés du
d'une europe un peu compliqué à plus
d'europe du tout donc je sais pas
comment cette majorité va pourrait
fonctionner fait randstad représentant
groupe qui est lui très pro européens
même si on est là qu elle et son mari
devait se tenir mais très dur ce tout
ceci en plus dans un contexte mondial
globalement un petit peu dérangé
theresa may son discours sur le break
site qui nous dit en fait que elle
n'attend rien de l'europe
ils sont prêts à sortir sortir du marché
unique sortir de l'union douanière qui
t'a potentiellement signé un accord de
libre échange avec l'union européenne
c'est un truc qui pour sa première
interview
maintenant qu'il a pris fin qu'il va
prendre son poste de président indique
qu'il veut la fin de l'europe
est ce que l'europe aujourd'hui peut
contrer les attaques
il n'y a pas que la main d'oeuvre en
réalité l'europe est en train de devenir
un îlot à l'intérieur d'un monde qui se
recompose mais qui se recompose contre
les valeurs de leurs noms à 30 on à
poutine
moi je n'oublie pas le rôle que joue
poutine et on à erdogan maintenant en
turquie qui est en train de rentrer donc
on voit bien qu'il ya une coalition qui
est en train de se faire l'europe essaye
de porter des valeurs parfois elles y
arrivent difficilement mais les portes
et on s'aperçoit que la trump risque de
jouer la carte
theresa may avec le la bienveillance de
monsieur poutine pour essayer justement
de porter atteinte à ce que défend
l'europe donc moi je suis suis très
inquiet sur le fait qu' on n'est pas la
capacité de porter la une gêne une
vision commune bien sûr que les verts
sont prêts à continuer à travailler
comme ils l'ont toujours fait dans
l'intérêt général d'une europe qui
progresse maintenant la difficulté c'est
que au sein du ppe et au sein de ses
airs et je parle pas de la ld eux parce
que c'est plus très clair
malheureusement avec guy verhofstadt qui
discute avec beppe grillo qui n'est pas
très clair mais moi je crains on à
monsieur ban qui portent pas
nécessairement et c'est un euphémisme
les valeurs que nous défendons
on a donc là on va on va on va vers des
tiraillements terrible veut or l'europe
est quand même en crise
donc moi j'aimerais qu'on arrive à
mettre vraiment un projet européen sur
la sur la table et pas simplement des
histoires de personnes
alors on va avancer il ya un autre
dossier en fait qui nous a occupés ces
dernières années notamment pendant la
crise c'est l'euro l'euro a fêté ses 15
ans au mois de janvier est fort de tout
ça malheureusement on s'est rendu compte
en cherchant un petit peu que les
monnaies locales pendant ce temps là
avaient fleuri depuis 2008
une manière en fait de répondre à la
crise mounir soucy s'est rendu en
sardaigne où justement une monnaie
locale et en étant circulation depuis
2008 ça s'appelle le sarde ex reportage
au coeur de la sardaigne dans cette
boulangerie presque centenaire les
affaires tournent bien
la famille vient d'ouvrir son huitième
point de vente sur l'île une prouesse
dans une des régions les plus pauvres
d'italie
une des raisons de cette bonne santé se
cache derrière cet autocollant
il indique que l'entreprise utilise une
monnaie locale qui lui permet de
commercer uniquement avec des
partenaires du territoire
l'élément intéressant avec le sarde ex
c'est qu'en accord avec les
gestionnaires du réseau
on peut par exemple mettre à disposition
l'équivalent de cinquante mille euros de
prestations point de faire allégeance
quand tu as atteint ce montant la valeur
générée doit être dépensé auprès des
autres adhérents du circuit et pour nous
ce sont souvent des matières premières
avec cette monnaie virtuelle
il n'y a pas d' échange d'argent un
entrepreneur qui fournit des biens et
services est payé en sardaigne
il peut ensuite les dépenses et sur le
réseau pour obtenir des prestations ou
acheter des matières premières sans
piocher dans sa trésorerie
ce sont les granulés de bois que l'on
utilise pour la combustion des fours on
se fournit auprès d'un partenaire du
circuit c'est intéressant car ces
granulés sont produits en sardaigne
donc on se fournit dans la région et on
le paye ans index
ça nous permet de couvrir un coût fixe
mais au lieu de le payer en euros
on le paye en sardaigne la gestion de
cette monnaie numérique est totalement
informatisé
vous savez quoi
je viens de m'apercevoir que j'ai besoin
de vent donc je vais faire une
transaction aux index
je vais sur le site je cherche mon
fournisseur je commande et je paie la
traversée
une simplicité d'utilisation mise au
point dans ses bureaux
la cinquantaine d'employés de la
start-up sarde ex fournit un support
informatique et commercial aux 3500
entreprises du réseau
l'aventuré a démarré au lendemain de la
crise financière de 2008
les créateurs ont cherché un moyen de
soutenir l'économie locale au moment où
les banques n'accordaient plus crédits
aux entrepreneurs
l'objectif principal à l'origine de la
création du serbe ex qui a été fondée
fin 2009 début 2010 était de faire
adhérer des opérateurs économiques du
territoire sarde afin de leur donner la
possibilité de commercer et d'échangé
est biens et services produits dans un
marché additionnel est parallèle à celui
de l'euro ce pari gagnant a permis de
maintenir l'activité au moment où
l'économie réelle étaient asséchées par
les dérives de la finance
aujourd'hui le succès est au rendez-vous
en 2016 l'équivalent de 70 millions
d'euros des changes a eu lieu sur la
plateforme
ce dynamisme a apporté une bouffée
d'oxygène au tissu économique local est
fait et les effets vraiment fait sentir
alors que si l'on regarde au niveau du
pib' il est clair qu'ils sont minimes
mais sur le plan local
ils ont été très forts pour un artisan
une entreprise ou un professionnel
l'activité tourne au ralenti la force du
réseau sar d'aix permet de leur trouver
des contrats et dans ce système des
changes basée sur la confiance
ils réussissent à augmenter leur chiffre
d'affaires le sarde ex a prouvé son
efficacité
mais pour cet économiste les monnaies
locales sont loin d'être la solution
miracle fonctionne à la maca monnaies
complémentaires ne fonctionne pas au
niveau macroéconomique ce sont des
monnaies virtuelles dont la validité est
reconnue dans un système fermé ça ne
peut pas marcher
à l'échelle d'un pays comme l'italie ou
la france comme pays comme l'italie la
france
m
havas l'air maussade mille habitants le
patron de ce magasin ne regrette pas
d'avoir rejoint le réseau sarde ex
membre depuis août 2016
il a vu son chiffre d'affaires
progresser de 10% chaque mois dans les
supermarchés de lille la part des
produits frais sarda doublé sur les
étals passant de 18 à 38 % car les
enseignes mettent en avant les produits
de leurs partenaires locaux
voici un exemple de nos pattes locales
dans ce rayon
il est une gamme de produits typiques
tous fabriqués au sein de ce modèle
s'exporte sur le continent ce hard ex
accompagne la moitié des régions
italiennes dans la création de leur
monnaie locale et l'entreprise rêve d'un
avenir à l'international des projets
sont à l'étude en grèce en équateur et
au kenya avec des partenaires séduits
par l'idée que l'économie peut
s'affranchir de la finance et des
banques
[Musique]
andreas faible quand on voit les sort de
ces monnaies locales est ce que c'est
par un petit peu l'échec de l'euro je ne
pense pas du tout alors si on regarde
bien ce qui a été dit si on écoute alors
les affaires vont bien
c'est probablement aussi grâce à l'euro
et quand je cherche avec ma famille des
destinations pour les vacances c'est
très cher là donc apparemment ça marche
assez bien et si les monnaies locaux
peuvent locales peuvent apporter un
atout j'ai aucun problème mais pour
l'europe comme ça a été dit ça ne peut
pas fonctionner et en allemagne en
france un peu partout on se moque de
l'euro mais on peut pas vraiment juger
qui aurait été la situation que horaire
était la situation sent le roussi et
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui ça c'est
quand même construit après la crise de
2008 au moment où les banques en fait on
a séché les crédits il a fallu relancer
le commerce relancer l'économie et on
s'est basé sur ces monnaies locales
s'est bien qu'à un moment il ya quelque
chose qui pêche autour de l'euro et de
peut-être du système bancaire européen
alors c'est facile de dire après qu'avec
ça ça a aidé mais après 2008
les conséquences pour l'italie pour la
sardaigne et pour la france et pour
l'allemagne et pour tous les autres
auraient été beaucoup plus beaucoup pire
beaucoup plus pire sans l'euro donc je
pense est très difficile de communiquer
ça aux citoyens car chacun est un peu
personnel dans son jugement veut mais
avec l'euro moi je reste convaincu c'est
mieux pour nous tous que sans vous êtes
d'accord parce qu'à lyon totalement
je suis d'accord sur sur les deux
constats la première c'est que moi je
n'ai pas oublié ce que disait type racé
varoufakis au moment de la crise grecque
les ministres grecs grève à référencer
un premier qui ont tous les deux dit que
tout en étant très critique sur le
fonctionnement de l'europe et sur
l'austérité on peut pas leur faire ce
reproche là ils ont souhaité rester au
sein de l'euro parce qu'on sait très
bien que la spéculation sur les monnaies
nationales auraient été extrêmement
grave et que notamment les grecs
allaient nous et avec la crise rendait à
plus de 17 % etc
l'euro a permis de mutualiser simplement
et moi je ne différencie pas les deux
c'est complémentaire ces monnaies
locales qui existe depuis longtemps en
angleterre qui existent en suisse qui
existent en bavière
sont très importantes pour relocaliser
l'économie donc c'est une excellente
solution notamment dans les territoires
qui sont les territoires en situation
difficile
la sardaigne les ça permet de
fonctionner en autarcie
ça permet de se soustraire à la logique
de la spéculation financière et donc
c'est en cela que c'est très bien parce
que c'est fermé
donc les banques n'ont rien à voir avec
le sait ça évite de sortir de la
trésorerie
et puis ça permet encore une fois de
relocaliser l'économie
c'est très important l'europe a besoin
de recréer des emplois sur ces
territoires
donc c'est une excellente nouvelle le
fait que ces monnaies se développe n'ont
rien à voir avec les monnaies nationales
parce que les monnaies nationales sont
dont la logique de spéculation avec des
attaquent avec des avec dédé des taux et
c'est donc l'euro doit rester notre
monnaie commune le chapeau qui nous
permet de mutualiser entre les pays en
situation de crise et des autres après
la gestion l'euro est une autre question
je suis très critique à l'égard de la
gouvernance de l'euro mais le principe
de l'euro à mon sens n'a pas être remise
en cause
et ces monnaies locales doivent être
développées et aider car elles
permettent à des territoires de s'en
sortir en dehors de la pression dans
caire ou financier alors vous vous avez
fait la transition vous même sur la
gestion de l'euro on a dit souvent et on
dit souvent encore que cet euro en fête
a été créé sur le modèle allemand sur le
modèle du deutsche mark
est-ce qu effectivement je m'adresse à
vous rendre et à cheval vous êtes député
allemand est ce qu'on n'a pas collé
l'euro sur le fonctionnement du deutsche
mark et du coup par conséquent et tous
fait un petit peu l'économie des pays du
sud notamment
bon on est où on en est donc maintenant
il faut regarder la réalité et la
réalité est que l'euro marche encore
assez bien malgré toutes les crises
autour de nous ça marche assez bien mais
c'est vrai que nous avons un enjeu à
régler et c'est la question comment ça
peut fonctionner au futur en ce moment
quand des états membres prennent des
engagements financiers
en fait en réalité c'est la banque
centrale européenne qui prend les coups
veut et qui garantit pour cette banque
centrale européenne bon nous tous mais
surtout ceux qui ont mis des engagements
là dedans et donc pour l'allemagne ou
long terme ça sera un grand a
un grand problème si on n'arrive pas à
une meilleure maîtrise des inégalités et
des balances c'est clair qu'il ya des
pays en difficulté il faut de la
solidarité
mais il ya aussi des pays qui devraient
faire plus pour revenir en balance et on
a malgré série d'arrêtés malheureusement
c'est pas le sofa wolfgang schauble qui
est votre ministre des finances n'est
pas vraiment sur cette ligne absolue à
voir le convaincre absolument mais c'est
très difficile de définir la solidarité
si vous êtes 20 ans en déficit de dire
le 21 et maintenant on peut pas changer
c'est pas la solidarité qu'on peut
demander dans ce cas c'est ce qui est le
cas de la france elle n'a jamais été
dans le pacte de stabilité
pascal durand oui elle ne l'est pas elle
fait des efforts pour y être cela étant
les situations sont difficiles
moi je l'aï dit tout à l'heure je défend
le principe de l'euro et je défend le
principe d'une solidarité européenne
c'est une évidence pour moi
après effectivement il ya des choses qui
sont inadmissibles
la manière dont on impose des réformes
forcés notamment sur la question du
droit social en grèce
me pose me pose de vrais problèmes et je
suis pas tout seul
alors oui il faut que l'allemagne évolué
mais moi je veux pas faire je pas
identifié un adversaire c'est
globalement la vision mois je
souhaiterais qu'on rééquilibre cette
europe sociale par rapport à l'europe
financière et économique
on a besoin des deux dans une démocratie
il faut trouver cet équilibre là on l'a
perdu
clairement on est rentré dans une
logique qui est trop financiers nourri
les discours anti-européen exactement et
donc à la fin c'est pas ça aux bleus
femme monsieur chat aux bleus ou
d'autres qui vont gagner ou perdre c'est
l'europe
si on n'arrive pas à remettre au coeur
de l'europe de demain et tout simplement
de l'humain de faire en sorte que oui il
ya des passages qui sont difficiles on
va pas s'en sortir
et là on parle de la grèce mais l'italie
va pas tellement mieux et est donc on
voit bien que le système bancaire est en
danger moi j'aimerais tellement qu'on
lance au niveau européen des obligations
que l'on relance y avait le grand débat
pendant justement la crise des dettes la
bce servent à ça on a des liquidités en
europe qu'on s'en serve pour relancer
des grands projets pour créer de
l'emploi pour recréer de la solidarité
au quotidien
voilà c'est ça le rôle de l'euro on a
souvent dit de l'euro depuis qu'elle
existe que cette monnaie avait fait
gonfler les prix alors on va inaugurer
avec vous messieurs pour cette nouvelle
séquence de 2017
notre checkpoint un checkpoint qui a été
réalisé en partenariat avec la rtbf nos
voisins belges grâce à qui nous faisons
aussi cette émission et pour en parler
c'est thomas mignon qui va nous
rejoindre pour nous expliqué thomas je
vous en prie qui va nous expliquer en
quoi cela consiste alors thomas chaque
semaine tu vas nous propose est en fait
une séquence qui s'appelle checkpoint
est comme son nom l'indiqué cette
séquence c'est une séquence de fact
checking ça consiste en quoi
et bien fact checking cette transaction
nous en dit déjà beaucoup c'est la
vérification par les faits donc c'est
vérifié si les faits ou les chiffres de
nos hommes et de nos femmes politiques
dans leurs discours se révèle exacte ou
non donc c'est un peu la règle d'or du
journalisme vérifier et puis si besoin
rétablir la vérité
alors est-ce que tu as un exemple
concret eh bien oui un exemple récent
celui du corexit donc juste avant le
référendum les partisans du liesse
avaient fait d'un chiffre leur slogan
350 millions de livres
nigel farrage on s'en souvient des
e-bonds hadj alpha edge voilà 350
millions de livres donc la somme que le
royaume uni débourserait pour être
membre de l'union européenne
chaque semaine chaque semaine 350
c'est ce qu'ils ont à fermer du moins
mais il s'est révélé qu'après il s'est
avéré après vérification que ce chiffre
était tout simplement par là moi je
crois que c'est pas vraiment démenti
voilà exactement et donc dans le cadre
de checkpoint l'idée c'est de vérifier
les faits et les chiffres qui concerne
l'union européenne bien longtemps oui
voilà on a dégainé ce qu'on pourrait
appeler notre thermomètre de la vérité
histoire de prendre la température des
discours des hommes et des femmes
politiques et débusquer les éventuelles
erreurs ou les mensonges qui circulerait
au sujet de l'europe
d'autant que c'est une année à enjeu
avec des élections bien sûr en france
mais aussi en allemagne ou encore aux
pays-bas et donc l'europe sera de tous
les débats avec la crise migratoire
l'espace schengen le terrorisme et
pourquoi pas peut-être cette question de
la monnaie unique et ben justement on va
découvrir votre thermomètre de la vérité
autour d'eux
l'euro et va l'euro at-il fait augmenter
les prix
c'est thomas mignon et c'est notre
checkpoint on le sait tous
l'euro n'a pas que des amis que ce soit
dans la rue ou sur les réseaux sociaux
la monnaie unique et marc fois critiqué
et une idée revient régulièrement
elle est même récupéré en politique
notamment par l'extrême droite
il n'est pas rare d'entendre que l'euro
est responsable d'une augmentation des
prix est tout d'abord les prix ont-ils
réellement augmenté depuis lors prenons
un exemple tout le monde connaît celui
du parc en france comme en belgique le
prix de la baguette a gonflé avant
l'euro notre baguette coûtait 60
centimes et quinze ans plus tard la
baguette affiche 85 centimes pour
l'ensemble des produits union européenne
calcule la hausse des prix à l'aide d'un
indice l'ipc h
l'indicé des prix à la consommation
harmonisé cet indice surveille
l'évolution du prix du panier de la
ménagère et nous montre que d'une année
à l'autre les prix ont pratiquement
toujours augmenter donc c'est un fait il
y a bien eu une hausse des prix mais
pour autant l'euro est il responsable de
cette augmentation
à l'époque défend il n'était pas rare
que les prix bondissent de 3 voire 4 %
et depuis la monnaie unique
c'est trop ce qu'ils étaient en moyenne
inférieure à 2% quant à ceux qui n'ont
pas l'euro comme la pologne ou encore le
royaume uni leurs résultats sont moins
bons il dépasse en moyenne ces deux
pourtant donc si les prix continuent bel
et bien d'augmenter
cette hausse est plus timide
qu'auparavant autrement dit si l'on
reprend notre baguette et bien son prix
grimper nettement plus vite avant l'euro
notre monnaie européenne aurait même
permis un tassement de cette
augmentation
la situation est meilleure depuis l'euro
et affirmé que l'euro est responsable
d'une augmentation des prix
c'est tout simplement fou en deux mots
et andres faible parce qu'elle durant
cette croyance que l'euro a fait
augmenter les prix l élu à quoi dans le
ceclr c'est pas vrai mais en politique
et en démocratie ce qui compte parce
c'est pas important d'avoir raison c'est
d'avoir c'était d'avoir une majorité
dans la population et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut augmenter notre pouvoir de
convaincre les gens qu'ils comprennent
cette logique qu'une pascal durand même
réponse c'est à dire qu'en gros on voit
que la réalité pas là après le prix de
la baguette on peut parler aussi de
l'augmentation du prix des matières
premières de la farine et serra mais bon
voilà il faut débattre
il faut expliquer il faut arrêter
d'avoir l'europe honteuse et essayer de
défendre les acquis européens l'euro en
est un voilà il faut mais il faut en
même temps ne pas être béat et savoir
critiquer mais l'euro n'est pas
responsable de l'inflation c'est clair
bon bah écoutez merci beaucoup en
attendant de nous avoir éclairé sur ces
questions et d'avoir des battus thomas
on vous retrouve la semaine prochaine
enfin pas vous mais le checkpoint avec
ahmed tazir à bruxelles pour nous c'est
la fin de cette émission très belle
semaine à tous ciao
[Musique]
à